*Continuous grunt* Bam!
Mark: Hello everybody, my name- Ohh, WHAT?!
You about to intrude?!
Ro: *Laughs*
*Thump* Bam!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to another challenge with Roooooo.
Ro: Hello! *waves*
Mark: Also known as Rosanna Pansino
And this is my diamond play button!
Ro: *sings like an angel*
Mark: If you don't know why this is here, you gotta go see the video over on her channel
where we did another Nerdy Nummies, just like
we did for Five Nights at Freddy's back then but I didn't have an award for that!
I have this, it's amazing
Are you gonna close up on that?
Ha ha, that's pretty nice.
Thanks
Anyway that going to be right here
SO!
We are reverting back to our playground days,
Ro: Yesss!
Mark: And we are gonna play with some PlayDoh!
Ro: Oh yeah!
Mark: So the challenge is...
we are both going to be getting a prompt..
and we have to sculpt...
...this mysterious thing that we're gonna be knowing in- in just a second,
Mike is behind the camera he's gonna shout it- Say hi!
Mike: Hi Mike.
*Ro laughs*
Mark: No...
Yeah so, we're gonna be given a prompt, we're gonna get this,
and then an impartial judge of THREE separate people:
Molly, Tyler, Mike, they're all gonna be doing
the judging for us, uh
and they're supposedly impartial.
They're not at all. Tyler even said as much that he was not going to vote for me
before this challenge started.
(Tyler laughs)
Ro: Wooo hooo  Mark: He explicitly stated that I was not gonna be voted for
Mike: Do you wanna maybe explain what you're doing?
Mark: I did! I explained it!
Ro: What about the points?
Mark: We're gonna be getting- oh...
Ro: Oh, the judges tell us
Mark: Yeah, we're gonna be getting a prompt. We're gonna make it out of PlayDoh.
It's best of five, we have one minute to make it.
So I'm gonna get ready and open, nah..
Ro: No! Yeah?
Mark: Yeah keep em' closed
Ro: We only have one minute?!
Mark: One minute.
Ro: Uh oh. *cough*
What if I cant get the lid off for like twenty seconds?
Mark: Well that's too bad for you!
Ro: Oh, okay...
Mike: Alright the first thing you're going to make is a beautiful, beautiful tiger. GO!
[Upbeat snazzy music] (dang, this should be my intro)
Mark: Oh jeez...
Ro: *laughing* Come out! (of the closet mark ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  )
Ro: Are you kidding?
Ro: Are you-- No! Are you kidding?
Mark: Heh ha!
Mark: Looks like I... Will be the victor!! *bang bang bang bang bang bang*
Ro: Okay... Okay a cat. He has a body, he has a body...                                   Mark: That is true
Ro: Four- four legs! Four legs.
Mark: That's true, cats do have bodies.
Mark: This one's gonna be stealthy, stalking through the jungle.
Ro: That's a tail... Mark: okay!
Mark: I'm gonna build some jungle...urng
Mark: That's a tree! That's a... That's a tree.
[Upbeat music] (this music makes me fappy ( ͡o ͜ʖ ͡o)  )
That's a tree, it's a frond of a tree
and it's hiding in the jungle. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
It's a, it's a Bengal tiger! My bro from Cincinnati,
here, cares about that stuff
Ro: We need stripes!
Mark: I'm get- I'm already on the stripes.                                                     R: What?
Mike: Alright time!
Ro: Oh, WHAT?! Oh! I didn't get any stripes! M: Oh geez... That's it?!
*Ro and Mark laugh*
Tyler: I vote Mark.
Mark: Yeah! *Laughs victoriously* Yeah! *claps*
'Cause it- it was the jungle that did it for ya, right?
Tyler: Yes
Molly: I'm gonna have to vote Mark too. *Mark gasps*
Because he got the stripes,
and has scenery.
Mark: Yeah! Ro: Wow, stripes AND scenery?
Really went the extra mile!
Ro: Ok... Mark: I want a clean sweep here.
Mike: It's Mark, because he was able to get the PlayDoh out.
Mark: Yeah! Ro: *laughing*
Ro: Nice job, Mark. Mark: Thank you
Ro: That was well deserved win! Mark: Thank you, yes.
Ro: Really creative! And he had those stripes.
Mark: I definitely deserve that. Mike: Your next item is: a delicious pizza! Go!
Ro: Oh (x6)
Ro: Okie, okie. Mark: *singing "Mozorellia"*
Mark: Italiano word
Ro: Not again! *Not* again! Really?!
*Rapid sledgehammer banging*
Mark: Okay, gotta get some nice...pepperoni on here.
Mark: Yeah, that's looking good.
Oh, I'd eat this!
*spits*
Ro: Okay!
Mark: Gotta get the Mozarella cheese!
Just flake that on there, gotta get all nice and flaky on there.
I mean, who doesn't like green peppers on their... Pizza there.
That's a delicious looking pizza... If I had to say.
Mark: I'm just gonna pretty it up with some nice crust going on here,
some elegant distribution.
Ro: I've got crust, I've got Marinara
Mark: I can make a stuffed crust pizza.
Ro *laughs*
Mark: There we go just gonna stuff that crust in there.
Just that one bite it's a SUPRISE bite of stuff. (Ro: Cheese, cheese, cheese)
You never know what's gonna be stuffed
I'm done! i think I can just... I think I'm... I'm good.
I'm confident in this.
ooh sausage! Thats a good idea, I'ma steal that idea!
AND TIME!
w-w-WHA-t!The sausage fell o-off, on the side! *Markimo laughs*
I feel pretty good about this
*in background* they're both good!
WHAT DO YOU MEAN THEY'RE BOTH GOOD?!
Ro: They're both really good!
oh they're both good..
wh- what is this double...di-
Tyler: I'm just curious about the orange crust...
Mike: I'm gonna go with Rosanna because
she has crust and sauce.
and I never had an orange pizza before..
*music intensifies* *Homicidal Mark in 3 2 1*
Ro: Uh Oh Mark: *skeptically* Sure
Molly: My vote is gonna go to Rosanna as well
Mark: AH COME ON!
I PUT SO MUCH DETAIL IN MINE Ro: *laughing*
Mark: I shredded the parma-the-the-the mazorella!
Molly: I think the sauce and the cheese
and the really round nice
shape of that-that pizza dough
*squeak* Mark: What's wrong with mine! I had a stuffed crust!
the crust was stuffed!
One crust was stuffed.
Ro: One crus- I can see him!
Mark: No this one.
Ro: Oh he's *laughs*
Mark: Right there.
Ro: Oh.
T: I'm sorry Mark, Rosanna.
Mark: *high pitch* WHAT? Ro: Wooooo!
That's- like a two year old could make that!
This takes skill and art! If- It's cause my sausage fell off, isn't it?
Cause my sausage...
*Tyler laughs*
Ro: Yeah... cause the sausage fell off that was it.
*small giggle*
*eviler giggle*
*witch cackle* Ro: Mark!
Ro: Mark! We're tied!
Mark: shut up
Ro: One To One!
Mike: Your next one... is a spooky, spooky jack o lantern. GO!
Ro: oh (x3)
Mark: I don't have enough orange for this!
Mark: *spoopy "oooohing"*
Mark: *spoopily* I'm setting the moooooddd.
It's spooooooky! Ro: *laughing*
M: It's got blood red eyeeeeees!
*weird "oohing" noise from Mark* They're so
angry! Vicious
fangs! Hes even got a little gangrene
in his eyeeee he's got
an infectiooon!
*mumbled: "It's So Spooooooky!"*
Mike: Alright time!
Mark: Argh!
*more spoppy Markimoo sounds*
*little laughy laugh and then mumbling*
Ro: *laughing* show the judges
Ro: *louder* Show the judges! Uh over heree
aw this is a tough one you guys
Mark: W-w-hat! No it's not!
Tyler: I-I've
I've got mine figured out
Molly: I think I know my vote too
Tyler: I vote Mark just because the color adds a
little bit more pop.
Mark: Thanks
Ro: Wow, Wow, wow, wow,
Molly: I'm gonna have to vote Mark too
Molly: for creativity
Ro: Tough Crowd! *smacks table lightly*
Tough Crowd! Molly: and uh ambience.
M: Eh yeah thank you! Thank you! You..
..rembember the ambience! Mike: I'll go with Ro
cause it actually looks like a Jack O' Lantern.
*Ro fistbumps air*
Mark: Wh-Why does mine not look like a Jack O' Lantern
*Ro crackles*
Tyler: I thought for sure one of you
was actually hollow it out and make holes
which would have been really cool.
Mark: That would have been smart but we are not that..
..thing. *assorted Tyler/Mike laugter* I think that's
biased! That's biased!
Mike: You still get the point Mark, be happy with it!
Mark: *refusing to admit defeat* ITS BIASED! It's 2-1.
Mike: Make a SUPER happy snowman! GO! :D
Ro: *ohh ohh ohh ohh ohh ohh* Wait!
(Insanity Mark) Ro: 2, 3
M: *breathy laugh* Ro: The biggest one on the bottom!
*Evilish laughter that goes to evil laughter*
*Satan laugh* MWAAHAHAHAHAHH
Ro: What is-what is that?!
Mark: *giggles*
Ro: Is that a happy laugh?
Mark: *evilish laughter*
Ro: *mumbling*
Mark: I'm happy about it!
Ro: Oh no!
Mark: It's a yellow
snowman *dissovles into giggles*
Mark: *grunts weirdly* Ro: He needs arms!
Mark: Looks like a penis!
[classical music]
Mark: yeaaahhhh!!
M: Oh that's cheating! Argh!
Ro: Ah no! Mark: Ok it didn't get in!
Mark: It's a neck brace!
Ro: *giggles and claps*
Mark: Alright, let me explain..
..mine *laughter*
Tyler: I already know yours!
Mark: *giggles* The happiness..
..that comes from a snowman comes from..
making the snowman.
All the little kids in town..
..had the best time making..
..the world's biggest
*hesitates* Ro & M: Yellow
snowman! They all..
..pitched in..
..it's the season of giving
*laughing* and they..
..couldn't stop giving..
Mark: so they had a great time
Ro *laughter*
M: Guess what the arms are..
..made of! *assorted no's from everyone*
Ro: Oh no!
Mark!
Okay! I have to go..
..with the snowman that i personally would want to build
and that would be Rosanna's  snowman
Mark: Oh, come on!     Ro: yes yes yes yes!
Mark:Thats like- thats the  Cutthroat kitchen round
i gotta give it to Ro
M: ohh, come on!
R: was not expecting that
to be frank
i could see that being like
aaaaa duck
like a rubber duck
M: How  is that duck?!
M: IN WHAT UNIVERSE IS THIS A DUCK?!
Ro: ooohhh ya
Ro: that you put in the bathtub
Ro: you know the little floaty duck in the bath
Mark: we are gonna talk about this when we get home
Ro:  *LAUGHS*
Tyler: It is truly hard, which is why I wanted to do a split vote
Mike: I think for creativity, Mark
but, for following the directions
i gotta give it to Ro
Mark: its a happy snowman!! *Ro woos in the backround*
Mark: I pretty much figured out i was gonna lose after
Mark: I had the idea
he literally went for yellow and looked directly at me and I'm like"oh god.."
Mark: Yah!
This is our last round and
big stakes because
Mark: TIED!
Ro: *nods* tied game.
it shouldn't be tied!
I think that the audience is in my favor on this one!
[beautiful music]
*shakes head*they're in your favor.
Markimoo: yeah-but thats just how
COOKIE CRUMBLES.
for the last one, you have to make,
YOURSELF!
*hammers play doh*
Mark: shizzle jo-inohn (chisel jaw) in there..
the epitome of maannliness
*struggles to get playdoh out* ERHHHH (x2)
come on!
Ro: Get out of there!
Mike: Time!
okay!
alright.
*laughter*
Ro: made myself, I have pale skin..
umm- i have PINK lips!
bruuunette hair!
AANNND
I tried to get some eyelashes on there
and a few chicken pox scars..
those i actually  - just, my finger just jammed in there.
my nail- but, i have a chicken pox scar
to match!
*nods* okay, alright!
So, mine,
I chose white skin..
because choosing yellow
would have been racist.
red, obviously, the hair is perfect
Perfect! Same! Same color!
I-I have an incredible
brown nose.
just-cause who I am.
The cheesiest smile.
Yeahh?
* everyone agreeing* YEahhhh
cheesy! (like da pizza!)
M:okay.
Ro :*nodding* okay
and then- uh- green eyes...
*speechless markimoo*
*wheeze*
Um.
Tyler: I'll go ahead and vote Mark
because he has all of the features of the face.
The nose, the eyes.
Ro: Yeah, missed the nose (who needs noses)
Mike: I think I'll go Ro, for artistic ability, I would much rather look at that
than Mark's. (Mark): Wha-you cant judge by artistic ab-
we didn't need pre-requisites coming into this!
Did we?!
Mike: As a judge, uh, that's what I pick!
Mark: *under breath* terrible judge..
Molly: HMMM....
Come downs to molly, but-uh
NEED I remind,
*laughter*
That I can BEAT YOU to DEATH with this thing?
It's very heavy!
Very heavy....*stares into molly's soul*
im a have to go with..
Rosanna.
OHHH!
It-
Molly:I actually saw it next to her face- I
I have to think that- there- um..
What!
that- I - and-
W-wHat!
Ro: Yeah, I don't know mark-I
What!
I- I
Ro: Id- the hair is you- but - i
Mark: w-w-w-What!
This is garbage! 100% Grade-A garbage!
I did not work my ass off, to win this!
*THUmp*
This award!
So i could be thwarted by
BIASED JUDGES!
Tyler: The funniest part is, you thought I was the ONE, who wasn't going to voting for him the most.
YOU STILL DIDNT!
*LAUGHTER*
You did 2 of 3 times, you voted for me!
Ro: wait, Im going to make you something!
Mark: what.
This will make you feel better.
I doubt that.
See? <3
Put it down.
There you go, there you go.
Thank you, I'm going to put this  right here.
you got that on camera?
*smash*
(ro:OOHH) Thats the end of the challenge, than you everybody so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed this video.
Check out the cupcake video we made over on her channel.
it's in the description below ↓
Thank you everyone for watching and let me know who REALLY won this down in the comments!
Mike: we all know they won't be biased, alright...
MINE WERE-BET
They had more heart, they had more soul!
they had more-like integrity..
Tyler: I-I I will give you, the uniqueness. Ro: yess
*creativity*
Ro:C-CC-RRR-ea-t-t-t-vity
U-a-nic-a-nious
Mark:THANK YOU
Tyler: artistic conscience, would not let me vote for this one so...
*mockingly* A-AR-R-TISTIC CONSCIENCE
OH-MY..
Ro: those are like- really DEEP words....and I like it!
*salty markimoo* Jesus...
Hey guys! I just got done editing this video
and I just wanted to add on
I'm not actually mad, it may seem like I'm salty
But I'm just playing that up because I thought that was funny
There's really kinda, no way that I could've won this challenge
uh, Ro's job is decorating pastries,
so Play-Doh's not too far off.
*BREATH*
And I highly recommend you guys check out the video we did for her channel
All about the Youtube Play Button
Except for the new RUBY one,
which I don't think any else besides Felix is ever gonna get. (You deserve it, Mark!)
so thank you everybody so much for watching,
and, and just remember, Ro is a lovely person
I adore her and  I love doing these videos with her.
so definitely check her channel out.
So thanks again everybody for watchin'
and as always, I will see YOU
in the next video.
Bye - bye!!